il y à laxou l'opéra l'opéra garnier un
vrai pas le lac des cygnes
on pensait qu'il s'agissait d'une
légende naît du fantôme de l'opéra de
gaston leroux mais tintin dalmas et
capitaine poirier ont voulu descendre
sous scène et ont vu faits sont garantis
le fantôme de l'opéra a pris corps ici
même grâce à l'imagination de gaston
leroux impressionné par l'étrange dédale
souterrain du palais garni naissance de
la légende du fameux spectre du non
moins fameux lac
or deux lacs de cavernes et luminae de
flambeau il n'y a jamais eu et de
rivières à truites encore moins le lac
est un réservoir 2000 tonnes à 11 mètres
sous la scène de l'opéra et aux mesures
du plateau 25 mètres sur 50 5860 charles
garnier remporte le concours de la
construction devant son ancien maître
viollet-le-duc son projet une énorme
pièce montée à l'image de la pompe du
second empire
dès les premiers travaux le site se
révèle marécageux à 8 mètres de
profondeur les infiltrations inondent de
chantier mais garnier ne va pas s'en
laisser compter par de l'eau toute bête
qui veut saper les bases de son palais
garnier de génie peu d'astuce au lieu de
lutter contre l'eau l'architecte ont
fait son allié gilles a été de la cub
pour contrebalancer la cdo et aussi
parce que l'eau se déposant dans cette
cuve à les recouvrir le sol d'aliments
qui couvrirait et b donnerait
complètement et c'est pourquoi on va
demander c'est comme cela n'a jamais
existé et didon ça nous mène où tous à
cette grande vadrouille dans le noir eh
ben je sais pas d'après le patron
monsieur charles garnier ça mène nulle
part
je